Can you tell me what is common between a frying
pan, a rope to hang your
clothes, an air tight container and a pair
of slippers?
Apart from the fact that they are all very
useful in everyday life, another
common thing is that they are made up of long
chains of repeating units.
In
simple words, they are made up of POLYMERS.
What exactly do we mean by polymers?
As the name says, “Poly” in Greek means
“Many” and “Mer” refers to “Units”.
So can we say, many repeating units joined
together?
Yes!
That is what it means.
And these units are all the same.
That means, the
basic unit that forms the polymer will repeat
itself several times.
Do we know
what this single unit is called?
Yes!
It is called a MONOMER!
So a monomer
repeats itself many times to form extremely
long chains which form nothing
but the POLYMER!
Polymers can be naturally occurring, or synthetic
which means man-made.
Now can you tell me… which among these are
natural and which ones are
artificial?
Well, all of them are artificial!
Yes!
The frying pan has a surface of Teflon, the
rope is made up of Nylon, the container is
Plastic and the slippers are simply
Processed Rubber!
Among all these examples, we are going to
focus on the rope and the
container.
We will focus on these two because we need
to understand the
concept of Synthetic fibres and Plastics.
Wait a second….what do we mean by Synthetic
fibres?
We have always used
cotton, wool, or silk which are naturally
occurring.
Do we know what synthetic
fibres are?
Of course we do!
The shiny clothes made up of rayon, the warm
and soft
clothes made up of acrylic are all what we
normally use.
These are all examples of Synthetic fibres.
As the name suggests, these are fibres made
by man.
That means the natural
fibres are chemically processed or maybe we
can even mix a few reagents to
get these artificial fibres?
Yes!
Absolutely!
That is exactly what we do.
There are several ways of obtaining synthetic
fibres.
In the upcoming videos, let us learn about
the types of Synthetic fibres and
their characteristics.
Then we will learn about Plastics being the
material of
choice and the effect of Plastic on our environment!